douche froide dans le ciel martiniquais
vous ne verrez plus ces avions volent et
après le 31 mars la compagnie
norvégienne a annoncé l'arrêt de ses
activités aux antilles à la fin de la
saison après quatre années de vol
saisonnier aux antilles françaises
norvégienne a pris la décision de ne pas
renouveler ces opérations la saison
prochaine il s'agit d'une décision
commerciale
en effet elle mettrait plusieurs
tentatives la rentabilité visée n'a pas
été atteinte
il ya plusieurs explications à cela tout
d'abord le coût extrêmement été pour la
compagnie d'ouvrir une base saisonnière
en guadeloupe ou en martinique et enfin
certaines routes qui n'ont pas atteint
des taux de remplissage satisfaisant
la compagnie low cost arrivé en décembre
2015 avait beaucoup d'ambition
les lignes vers les états unis avaient
pris un bon départ
je pense que très vite vous allez voir
seront ici en permanence
nous allons revenir avec d'avantagé
davantage
et à la saisonnalité en europe piège
mais en hiver nous ne voulons pas
tellement nous pouvons porter nos forces
ici quatre ans plus tard fini les belles
promesses norvégienne affiche une dette
de 3,5 milliards d'euros et a annoncé un
plan de 200 millions d'euros d'économies
résultat la compagnie arrête les
rotations chez nous coup dur pour notre
tourisme 60000 nord américains ont
visité notre île la saison dernière
grâce à elle